kevin how are we doing
hey uh not too bad how you doing john
anthony i'm standing outstanding how can
we help
yes um so i am on baby step two um
and i have uh my federal student loans
uh sandwiched in between my
my consumer debt and then my private
student loans
um i don't know if i should um postpone
the
the federal student loans due to the um
biden administration now
all sorts of uh okay no no
no no so pretty much just just go for it
yes and listen and this has nothing to
do with biden this has nothing to do
with president trump this has nothing to
do with that
do not wait on the government to take
care of your house bottom line
right okay and let's just say biden and
his administration present something to
the congress it still has to get
approved due to congress
and studies have shown us facts have
shown us
student loan forgiveness is not
happening now i'm not saying it
cannot happen in the future but what i
am saying is
man you you sound like a smart young man
you sound like you know exactly what you
need to do
what i'm saying is you start going down
the journey
to take care of your house and then if
the government does do something
to they do forgive they do do some stuff
like that then yes take advantage of it
but as of right now do not postpone your
future
at the possibility of what the congress
and what the president administration
may do
uh because facts are showing us it may
not happen bro and kevin
right this is just a this is a character
question
yep did you walk into an office and look
down at a piece of paper
and sign your name and say you're going
to help me go to school and we'll pay
you back
yes or no wait sorry can can you repeat
that question
sure if i walk
did you walk into your financial aid
office and you look down the piece of
paper
and somebody that you don't even know
said i'm gonna give you the money to go
to school and you said i'm gonna pay you
back
i'm gonna sign my name to this piece of
paper assuring you that i'm going to be
a person a character and pay you back
no yeah after reading um dave's book
yeah that's
that's not what i should have done in
this i'm just saying is that what
happened
uh yeah it pretty much is yeah i was a
little naive to sign yeah
yeah yeah we all were we all were we all
were right we're on the same boat
i had a bunch of zeros after my loans
but the reality is like anthony said
waiting for some some dragon to come
through
and you know some fairy godmother to
come take away
what you said you were going to do you
said yeah you loaned me
i'm going to pay for it to me it's a
character issue man do the best you can
get that paid off keep it in line and
then keep rocking and rolling man
you know we'll talk about this after the
break because i agree with you
50 it's a character issue because the
other 50 percent of why i do not agree
as a character issue because i think a
lot of these young people don't know
what they did
oh i agree there's some predatory
there's a predatory part to it no
question yeah so it's like
50 yeah character issue 50 is naive just
didn't know
that's right you know what i'm saying